memories warm you up from the inside
but they also tear you apart
unfortunately
the clock is ticking
the hours are going by
the past increases
the future recedes
possibilities decreasing
regrets mounting
spend your money on the things money can
buy
spend your time on the things money
can't buy
pain is inevitable
suffering is optional
when you look at the sea for a long time
you start to miss people
and when you look at people for a long
time
you start to miss the sea
whatever it is you're seeking
won't come in the form you're expecting
if you only read the books that everyone
else is reading
you can only think what everyone else is
thinking
nobody likes being alone that much
i don't go out of my way to make friends
that's all
it just leads to disappointment
no matter how much suffering you went
through
you never wanted to let go of those
memories
i dream
sometimes i think that's the only right
thing to do
don't feel sorry for yourself
only do that
[Music]
anyone who falls in love
is searching for the missing pieces of
themselves
so anyone who's in love gets sad when
they think of their lover
it's like stepping back inside a room
you have fond of memories of
one you haven't seen in a long time
listen up
there's no war that will end all wars
[Music]
if you can love someone with your whole
heart
even one person
then there's salvation in life
even if you can't get together with that
person
death is not the opposite of life
but a part of it
in everybody's life there's a point of
no return
and in a very few cases
a point where you can't go forward
anymore
and when we reach that point
all we can do is quietly accept the fact
that's how we survive
taking crazy things seriously
is a serious waste of time
i can bear any pain
as long as it has meaning
in this world
there are things you can only do alone
and things you can only do with somebody
else
it's important to combine the two in
just the right amount
the most important thing we learn at
school
is the fact that the most important
things
can't be learned at school
that's what the world is
after all
an endless battle of contrasting
memories
what a terrible thing it is to wound
someone you really care for
and to do it so unconsciously
chance encounters
are what keep us going
a certain type of perfection can only be
realized
through a limitless accumulation of the
imperfect
no matter how far you travel
you can never get away from yourself
when you come out of the storm
you won't be the same person who walked
in
that's what this storm's all about
you can hide memories
but you can't erase the history that
produce them
people leave strange little memories of
themselves behind when they die
errors are punctuation marks of life
without which
as in the text
there will be no meaning
a profession should initially be an act
of love
and not a marriage of convenience
until it's too late do not forget that
the work of a lifetime is not a business
but life
you need to spill your feelings out
worse if you stop doing it otherwise
they will accumulate and harden inside
and then die
wine that you drink alone
has almost no taste
being honest to each other
and wanting to help is the main thing
if someone wants to humiliate you
then you are on the right track
the most important thing is not the big
one that others have thought of
but the little thing that you yourself
came to
those who want to enter my life
enter it
and those who want to leave
leave it
a thing that carries a certain
imperfection in itself
attracts precisely its imperfection
the tragedy of a person
no matter how comical
is not in his shortcomings
but rather in his merits